Now, we will announce the new promotions.
Promotees to 8th Dan will receive their certificates individually.
Master Kimura Jiro
This is to certify that Kimura Jiro
is awarded the 8th Dan in Aikido.
Made on the 10th of January 2016,
Aikido Doshu Ueshiba Moriteru.
Master Miyamoto Tsuruzo
This is to certify that Miyamoto Tsuruzo
is awarded the 8th Dan in Aikido.
Made on the 10th of January 2016,
Aikido Doshu Ueshba Moriteru.
Master Christian Tissier.
This is to certify that Christian Tissier
is awarded the 8th Dan in Aikido.
Made on the 10th of January 2016,
Aikido Doshu Ueshba Moriteru.
This time, the total number of people promoted from 1st Dan to 8th Dan is 729.
The ceremony is finished.
Please wait for a while,
while we setup.
Kimura Jiro Sensei please.
Kimura Sensei, thank you very much.
Let's continue with Miyamoto Tsuruzo Sensei please.
Happy New Year.
I am Miyamoto from Hombu
thank you as always.
This time,
Having been promoted by Doshu,
I feel a strong sense of responsibility
I would like to thank the various teachers and sempai.
Also,
having been promoted in you presence,
it is a true honor,
and something I will not forget for the rest of my life.
Aikido training is Katageiko,
there is a lot of repetition of the same things,
but I noticed that even within that repetition, one discovers new things.
Aikido cannot be done alone.
I will likely rely upon you many occasions and look forward to keep training with you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you very much Miyamoto Sensei.
Now, coming from France, please welcome
Christian Tissier Sensei.
Doshu, Dojo-cho, Tada Sensei, all the Sensei, thank you very much.
I entered Hombu Dojo 47 years ago
and since that time, I have been faithful to the Ueshiba family.
From today, and tomorrow, I will continue to give my very best for Aikido.
Thank you very much.